today's intense waves seem to have been
triggered by the government's
announcement of something they're
calling the Patriots oath a
state-sponsored initiative to have
Americans sign a loyalty waiver I'm
serious this is crazy
the deadline for signing is the day
after Thanksgiving Black Friday hey it's
gonna be scary in the next couple days
I just gotta remember who we are we're
not gonna let them change it we are no I
[Music]
can't good to see you Happy Thanksgiving
what not Katie Abby can you watch the
Chris Rock on like that he's racist
Chris Rock's not racist she's best
friends with Adam Sandler that is a fact
you know it's actually it's racist to
think Chris Rock's racist Vanessa what
did he do you lit a copy of the oath on
fire in front of some constituents that
is so not illegal you could do whatever
you want to take the American flag and
shove it up your [ __ ]
certo politics what are we doing how's
this gonna get rich percentage-wise who
do you think it's in more car accidents
in this country white men or Asian women
Asian women no dad no white men I
wouldn't have said it if it was Asians
you
you